if you've been playing games in your
smartphone or tablet you've probably
noticed how far graphics have advanced
over the past few years well according
to a RM a leading manufacturer of mobile
graphics processors your phone could
surpass your xbox one in PlayStation 4
by 2017 according to a VentureBeat
report a RM company director nizar rom
done explained at the casual connect
conference in amsterdam the technology
capable of rendering visuals on par with
sony's and microsoft consoles are
currently in development arum is
currently working with Samsung Nvidia
and Texas Instruments mobile hardware is
already powerful ramadan said if you
take today's high-end smartphone or
tablet the performance is already better
than xbox 360 and PlayStation 3 it's
catching up quickly with Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 Ramadan noted that this
power increase could benefit virtual
reality as well our view is that mobile
VR is the use case that could unlock the
potential of mobile for hardcore gamers
instead for once mobile devices are on
par with PC and console in terms of
experience we don't have the same
processing and battery life is a problem
but it is the same user experience that
could be a game-changer for mobile
gaming according to a report from super
data the VR industry will generate 5.1
billion dollars in 2016 the oculus rift
ships on march 28 for six hundred
dollars a price or release date for
PlayStation VR has not been announced
but it is expected to arrive this year
while pre-orders for the HTC vive open
up on februari 29th and ship this April